so uh how long did it take for the three
of you when you got on set with Arnold
to to literally start peppering him with
questions about his career five seconds
immediately yeah it's like I wouldn't
care to shake your hands sir so how did
you do it how do I become a success
story like you you know and and but the
cool thing is you sometimes you get
nervous to ask people questions and it's
like you want to be his peer and not
just a fan but the thing about Arnold is
everybody's his peer he treats everybody
equally and loves supporting to you and
he's like a the grandfather you always
wish you had who's full of stories you
ask him one question be prepared to sit
there for at least 15 minutes to hear a
story about something that'd be okay
with that yeah right
15 minutes well spent oh I was
fascinated because we we sat in the
hallway right after our first scene and
you know he knew I did stand up so he
started telling me all these stories
about Milton Burrell and all of the
roasts that he would go to and just I
mean these really iconic moments from
you know that Hollywood history you're
just captivated by it completely I've
been asking this of everyone uh do you
have a favorite Arnold movie Last Action
Hero has always been mine that was one
that really stood out to me and when I
first met Arnold I had to get that out
of the way right out of the gate I had
to say hey I just have to praise you for
a second and I told him all my favorite
movies and all the ways he's impacted my
life and then I was like okay now we can
like get to know each other but I would
say Last Action Hero was is my favorite
I mean I'm Kindergarten Cop because you
know comedy is my thing and I that that
movie comes on now and I will stop and
watch it
and I will have to say jingle all the
way because every Christmas I definitely
watched that movie and it is a blast
jingle all the way I've not heard before
I'm just gonna give you props
um so jumping into Fubar uh so the
series is Eight Episodes seen the first
four which is your favorite episode and
why hands down episode seven is my
favorite episode because
that is when Barry you know opens up his
romantic life to the world and it
doesn't go well for him but at least he
tries
uh I think mine are the last two because
uh I got to have an emotional Arc and
learn you learn a lot more about my
background I also get to act uh kind of
ridiculous uh is that seven seven yeah I
get that ridiculous I won't tell you why
and I mess up some things as a result uh
so I not only got to do uh a lot of the
crazy comedy and that but then I got to
to shift it into this emotional Arc and
um and have a little bit more serious
moments I would say episode three was
probably my favorite because I got to
I I really got to start showing the
underbelly of my character but I got to
do a lot of the Han Solo moments and
have some really really really fun
action scenes and it kind of my
character kind of comes onto the scene
in that episode called this up Han Solo
gotta love it I love it
okay straight from Nick santora
I love learning about the behind the
scenes the making of shows and movies so
for soon to be fans of the show uh what
do you think they would be surprised to
learn about the actual making of the
show hmm
uh that there was no real train
the trains oh I mean the plane's not
real like they made all that stuff but
like very impressed I mean it was
impressive what they made yeah our set
architect or designer not sure what you
call them that man is par none like it
is it is ridiculous the things he was
able to create from the Train the plane
uh from even like the silos that uh we
get trapped in I have to climb through
uh I have a scene where I have to go
through a tunnel and then he built a
jail how do you build a Turkish prison
and you build the tunnel right and that
bunker I mean everything was really well
done maybe a surprise would be that they
would know that we filmed episode six
last oh that that is I wonder if you'd
be able to tell that that was filmed out
that was the last one yeah you probably
can't tell but that's oh I've also
spoken to people who filmed like the
redo the first episode at the end of the
shoot because they had to do some
reshoots it's crazy how Hollywood Works
um uh what's a scene that you thought
would be what's the scene you got on the
the first day on the first take or
what's a scene that you thought would be
super easy and ended up taking like
forever oh my goodness uh I'll go first
in this one so as you know uh Merry
Fitness is like you know we're in the
CIA we gotta have our little secret lair
Mary Fitness is the cover that we have
and day one of shooting there the way
that it opens our Lair we had a lot of
technical difficulties so even though
there was only a few lines it felt like
it took forever to shoot that because we
couldn't time the doors perfectly mine
was uh saying boro's last name I was
trying to rhyme it with uh was it
bologna bologna and Paloma and you know
it was like oh it's a simple rhyme it
took me like 30 minutes to get it right
and they kept stopping but that's not
right but it is and then she finally got
it right and then she messed it up
herself
like no that was the day it was a tongue
twister that and I had to write
equations on the board uh but I couldn't
write on the board so I had to met they
they made the equation appear as I wrote
and I had to match it as I was saying
lines and that took a lot more timing
than I would have ever guessed I would
say for me my character is a linguist
and I had to speak uh Kazakh and I would
say that episode two having to come in
the stakes are really high the pace is
so fast and to have to get that dialect
down there was definitely some you know
some stop and starts during during that
uh it's gonna be my last question and uh
Travis it's an individual one for you if
you don't mind
um I'm a big fan of Doug Lyman and I
believe you are part of uh uh Roadhouse
um
I'm just I was waiting for a reaction
I'm like did I get this wrong I said
let's go what was it like being part of
that uh film and what can you tease uh
like how does it compare to the original
uh first of all it's Doug Lyman so you
know it's going to be great you know
this man just knows how to make a film
uh it's Jake Gyllenhaal getting to work
with him you know talk about working
with Schwarzenegger that was a dream
getting to work with Jake that that's
another moment for me that's that's just
a highlight of of my life so far in my
profession
um also I got to meet Conor McGregor
which was just another like I just to be
uh in a film I don't know how it's not
going to be the exact same as the last
Roadhouse I I think it'll be an addition
to it
um
but I I think you guys are gonna like it
it's a pretty it's a pretty tight film
on that note I'm just gonna say I hope
this show is a huge hit for you guys and
I wish you nothing but the best all
right thanks brother thank you
appreciate it